- [Narrator] We're all
familiar with Coca-Cola.
But this is also Coke.
It's said that clear Coke
was a top secret project
made exclusively for
a thirsty Red Russian.
(light music)
- Ah, so good.
- [Narrator] During World War II,
Coca-Cola made a global splash,
boosting American troops' morale.
At one point, Dwight D.
Eisenhower met with Georgy Zhukov,
a Soviet general
instrumental in the defeat
of Nazi Germany.
(explosion)
Eisenhower introduced him to Coke.
- [Eisenhower] Try this.
- [Narrator] Zhukov was hooked.
But after the war, Coke
was seen as a symbol
of American imperialism
and was banned from the Soviet Union.
Yeah, nope, not here.
So Zhukov called up none other
than U.S. president Harry Truman
to send him a secret stash.
- [Zhukov] I'm gonna need Coca-Cola.
- [Narrator] Truman
agreed to help Zhukov out.
- [Truman] Alright, you got it.
- [Narrator] He got the
top dogs at Coca-Cola
to disguise its iconic look.
They eliminated the
drink's artificial coloring,
but made sure the new vodka look alike
still had that classic Coke taste.
They packaged it in
straight glass bottles,
capped with a red star.
According to a World War II Coke rep,
50 cases were sent to Russia.
Zhukov got his fix.
He was never caught
with the disguised Cola,
and as far as we know,
it hasn't been sipped since.
(laid back music)